a murder that shocked an upscale
California neighborhood is now the focus
of an international manhunt
multi-millionaire businessman Peter
Chadwick and his wife QC disappeared
from their Newport Beach home back in
2012
now Chadwick was later charged with her
murder for allegedly staging her death
after posting his 1 million dollar bail
he then just vanished
now u.s. marshals are revealing key
clues to 48 hours that may lead to
Chadwick location 48 hours Tracy Smith
is following this manhunt after Peter
and QC Chadwick went missing the first
sign of trouble was found in their
Newport Beach home sergeant Brian Peters
and Lieutenant Brian Moore worked the
case in the master bathroom they
initially saw the broken glass we had
blood at the bottom of the bathtub hours
ticked by with no sign of the couple
until early the next morning when Peter
Chadwick showed up in a gas station near
the Mexican border a hundred miles away
from his home and called 911 is wife
q-see had been murdered my wife's dead
and this was a huge break this was huge
they took her 1 1 Chadwick claimed that
he took a house painter named Juan no
last name given to his home and one
attacked his wife drowning her in their
bathtub he then threatened Chadwick with
a 2-inch pocketknife and Juan orders
Peter to help him get KUSI's body out of
the tub with Juan at his side Chadwick
claimed he was forced to drive all
through the night with his wife's body
in the back of his SUV he said that Juan
then drove off with cue C's body leaving
Chadwick alone at that gas station
picked up Peter Chadwick and immediately
found holes in his story
any signs of one at all no
police say Chadwick is seen at a toll
shortly after he left his home with no
sign of Juan in the vehicle everyone we
talked to and described this one
individual no one had any idea who that
was or could give us any information
related to this person what's more
Chadwicks own body had some
incriminating injuries he had scratches
on his neck and arms you know bite mark
on his forearm just six hours after
making that 9-1-1 call Peter Chadwick
was arrested for murder
he wasn't defensive angry sad emotional
in any way Q C's body was eventually
found in a dumpster she'd been strangled
in court Peter Chadwick pleaded not
guilty he was granted one million
dollars bail no problem for the
multi-millionaire businessman so as
you're looking down the road you were
thinking Peter Chadwick is going to end
up where in prison but Peter Chadwick
had other plans and vanished
don'tdon't on Tracy Smith joins us at
the table interesting he makes up
somebody named Juan that did go on the
run why can't he be
Poindexter or something like a question
stand right simply it conjures up an
image it's not very nice
so he's a wanted fugitive where do
people where did the police rather think
he is today
well here's the thing he could be
anywhere because he drained his bank
accounts before he split of about a
million dollars that could take you
anywhere in the world so they've looked
in Japan Mexico Ukraine have had leads
all over the place he literally could be
anywhere the scratches on the body
seemed pretty animating what was the
motive yeah I why would he kill us we
found a handwritten note that said
Peters computer search history and on
that note it looks like it was in queues
he's writing were things like escort
services divorce how to torture someone
so what they think is that she
confronted Peter with this and then
there was a fight and it led to her
death oh let's hope somebody sees
something on 48 hours on Saturday night
the day before your big interview with
Howard Stern on Sunday morning gorgeous
thank you for mentioning that all the
time did you like Howard Stern I did
like Alex Berg you'll see a different
side of Howard Stern odd so I know I've
heard it teasers are piling on top of TV
you can watch Tracy Smith's 48 hours
report hash tag fine Peter Chadwick
Saturday at 10:00 9:00 central right
here on CBS